Democrats compete for attention on CNN
the media downplay Srilanka and Nancy
Pelosi plays footsie with impeachment
i'm ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro
show oh man last night was a smorgasbord
of various smorgasbord smorgasbord of
various Democratic candidates on CNN all
sort of looking kind of terrible and
we'll get to all of that in just one
second first let's talk about that
hideous suit that you've been wearing
around for the last two years I know you
got it off the rack I know it was too
expensive but you shouldn't have done
that
instead what you need to do from here on
in at least get this thing soft you need
to go over to Indo Chino Indo Chino is
the world's most exciting
made-to-measure menswear company that
makes suits and shirts to your exact
measurements for an unparalleled fit and
comfort if you are in the middle of
planning a wedding they have tons of
options for people who are looking to
outfit their wedding party I love the
wide selection of high quality fabrics
and colors to choose from not to mention
the option to personalize the details
including your lapel lining pockets
buttons monogrammed here's how it works
you can visit a stylist at one of their
showrooms because endo Chino has over 40
showrooms in North America it will take
your measurements personally or you can
measure at home and shop online at endo
chino comm you choose your path fabric
inside now you design the customizations
and then you submit the measurements
with the choices online and relax while
your suit gets professionally tailored
and mailer to you and mailed to you in
just a couple of wait of weeks this week
my listeners can get any premium Indo
Chino suit for just 379 bucks at Indo
Chino comm when you enter Shapiro's at
checkout that is 50% off the regular
price shipping is free Indo Chino kaam
promo code Shapiro for any premium suits
for just 379 bucks free shipping
incredible deal for a premium
made-to-measure suit again you don't
look like James Bond without having to
spend James Bond prices once you go
custom you don't go back check out Indo
Chino kaam promo code Shapiro ok so last
night was a big night on CNN because
there was a town hall event and a
variety of Democratic candidates made
appearances on this town hall event oh
it was exciting oh it was wonderful oh
it was terrifying absolutely terrifying
because the fact is that when you look
at the Democratic Party right now
there's only one thought leader one and
he's an octogenarian
socialist loom bag from Vermont who has
never passed a significant piece of
legislation
and was so lazy that in the 1970s he was
kicked out of a commune that guy is
their thought leader let's have some
theme music
I think y'all know who I'm talking about
that's right it's Bernard mix Anders so
senator Bernie Sanders is obviously the
thought leader of the Democratic Party
he's leading in the polls right now he's
pulled even basically with Joe Biden who
has yet to declare Biden expected to put
out some sort of video declaration later
this week to win the nomination all you
have to do is not be a crazy person at
this point but all the Democrats are
firmly convinced that Twitter is real
life and that the extreme edge of their
party is representative of the
mainstream of their party and so Bernie
Sanders with his 25% base seems to be
the guy who's leading Democrats over a
cliff for every crazy thing that he says
they're a bunch of Democrats who will
mirror it he really is an astonishing
thing and it's reminiscent of 2016 when
President Trump would say something that
was pretty extreme and other Republicans
would rush to follow suit or they would
rush to pretend that he was right about
it so for example on trade president
Trump would come out against the
trans-pacific partnership he talked
about how trade deals were really bad
and suddenly all the Republicans would
rush to surround him you hear the patter
of their little feet
Trump would walk over here he'd stomp
over there and then your turn and there
are all the Republicans following him
well it's the same thing right now with
Bernie Sanders Bernie says something
loony and all the Democrats rush to
follow him so last night's example of
Bernie saying something incredibly
incredibly Looney is he was talking
about his proposal to let people in
prison vote now this proposal is asinine
in the extreme it's asinine because if
you're in prison you have not paid your
debt to society yet there's an argument
to be made that when you get out of
prison that you should be able to vote
because now you have paid your debt to
society and if we don't want people
voting when they get out of prison or
participating in normal life when they
get out of prison maybe they shouldn't
be out of prison if you're afraid
they're dangerous or that they have not
paid their debt to society then perhaps
we should keep them there but if you
believe that somebody went to jail for
shoplifting or somebody went to jail for
securities fraud and now they've served
10 years 15 years for securities fraud
and they get out and they should never
be allowed to vote again right if you're
Dinesh D'Souza and you went to jail for
some sort of campaign finance violation
of federal violation can you vote or not
it seems like there's an argument to be
made I'm not super warm on the argument
at least there's a logical argument to
be made that once you have paid your
debt to society and you get out now you
get to vote Bernie Sanders is going even
further he wants people who are in
prison to vote number one they should
because there are Ward's of the state if
you're a ward of the state you should
not be able to vote that is because you
have an inherent interest in maximizing
the power of the states and the benefits
of the states and legislators who will
give you what you want Amanda let's put
this way using the content imperative if
we took this rule and extended it
outright to the rest of society if every
person in the you know if only prisoners
voted let's say that only prisoners
voted in the United States do you think
that the world would do better or worse
what do you think they would do at the
criminal law what do you think they
would do with social benefits do you
think the United States would be a
better place or a worse place so we take
the worst people in our society people
so bad we remove them from our society
and put them behind bars and then we
give them the right to vote this is
Bernie Sanders his proposal in his asked
a logical question by an Karl Stein who
is a student at Harvard University who
asks him um how about like the Boston
bomber you want him voting - and Bernie
being Bernie cannot help himself you
have said that you believe that people
with felony records should be allowed to
vote while in prison does this mean that
you would support enfranchising people
like the Boston Marathon bomber a
convicted terrorist and murderer if
somebody commits a serious crime sexual
assault murder they're going to be
punished they may be in jail for 10
years 20 years 50 years their whole
lives that's what happens when you
commit a serious crime but I think the
right to vote is inherent to our
democracy yes even for terrible people
okay so that's an insane answer so we
remove your right to the freedom remove
your right to engage in commerce but the
right to vote is so sacrosanct that
people who are evil vicious murderers
should be able to vote then who are in
prison right now and let me remind you
he is talking about some of the worst
people on planet earth I just have to
recall here what actually happened at
the Boston Marathon bombing at the
Boston Marathon bombing the bomber his
two brothers the bomber who actually
planted the bomb at the Boston Marathon
bombing took a backpack filled with a
bomb and he placed it about two feet
away from an eight-year-old boy he
placed a two feet away from an
eight-year-old boy killed the boy on the
spot boy bled out in front of his
parents blew the leg off his sister
Bernie Sanders think
that person should have a say in the
future of the United States because
that's what a vote is it's a say in the
future of the United States Bernie
Sanders believes how vicious do you have
to be to believe that these people
should have a say in the future of the
United States how much must you think
it's so self contradictory in a variety
of ways one we must think that America
is a pretty horrible place that people
who are the worst among us should have a
say in what happens to the future of the
country that somehow they've been
oppressed or something I mean what
exactly is the justification here and
secondly how vicious as a person must
you be to ignore the evil that somebody
commits in order to say that that person
should be able to vote on what happens
to the family of the person whose kid
they murdered that's what a vote is
after all so they get the side policy by
which the person whose child they murder
lives it's insane the father of that
young boy martin richard talked about
talked about his son in the middle of
the trial he described what happened
that was not the only person was killed
in the Boston Marathon bombing to other
people 29 year old Krystle Campbell and
23 year old lingzi Lu were also killed
260 people were injured in the attack
people who lost legs people who lost
arms people who are who are hit in the
head
the father addressed the court back in
describing what happened they ducked
into a Ben & Jerry's for ice cream and
then found a spot to watch the runners
near the finish line there's a
photograph showing the Richard family as
they watched the race Martin had climbed
on the medal cranberry to get a better
look his family didn't know that no that
just then seen in the same photograph an
arm's length away was the bomber
allegedly dropping a backpack with the
bomb inside it went off a few minutes
later their daughter Jane lost her leg
Martin was killed outright he said I saw
a little boy who had his body severely
damaged by an explosion I just knew from
what I saw that there was no chance he
was eight years old Bernie Sanders yeah
why not he should vote just because he's
a bad guy doesn't mean that he shouldn't
vote it's truly incredible now as we
will see as we will see other Democrats
like lemmings are following Bernie
Sanders over this cliff he was not the
only person to be asked this question
last night and all the other Democrats
are so afraid of Bernie Sanders his
support base that they decide that they
are going to just trail him right off
that cliff even the most
moderate Democrats are making the case
that if you're a murderer and you get
out of prison then you should be allowed
to vote they're not making exceptions
for so I said earlier that if you get
out of prison for like securities fraud
maybe you should be able to vote I feel
like if you kill somebody you should not
be able to vote I feel like if you rape
somebody your right to vote is gone
yeah there's certain Krumpet but those
are also crimes where I feel you should
be in jail the rest of your life I don't
think that you should serve 10 years for
murder I think you should serve the rest
of your life for murder I don't think
you should be 5 years for rape I think
that if we have a forcible rape that is
found
statutory rape is a little bit different
because you may have a 19 year old in
the 14 year old for example that's a
problem it's not quite the same thing as
a 19 year old forcibly raping a 14 year
old that's why the law makes a
distinction they're both evil there are
gradations of evil but those good there
are certain gradations of evil beyond
which even if you get out of prison I
don't think that you should vote we'll
get to that in just a second but the
Democrats there were some Democrats last
night who even went so far as to say
that they would consider Bernie Sanders
his proposal to let the Boston Marathon
bomber vote it's truly incredible I want
to finish with Bernie and then we'll
move on to these other candidates
because what you're gonna see is Bernie
says something and the rest of the
Democrats follow him and this is why
Bernie right now is the front-runner now
maybe that changes when Joe Biden jumps
in the race but only if Joe Biden is
willing to stand up for his own record
if Joe Biden feels the necessity to also
apologized for his moderation if Joe
Biden feels the necessity to apologize
for his tough-on-crime record in the 90s
or for his opposition to forced busing
which was bad policy it was that pilot
whose failed policy in the 1970s if Joe
Biden feels the necessity to run away
from the only palatable parts of his
record in order to try and cater to
Bernie Sanders his base Bernie walks
away with the nomination because if
you're gonna if you're gonna go extreme
you go extreme if you're gonna drink
this whiskey you drink it straight you
don't mix it that's the Democratic Party
voters are thinking right now we'll get
two more Bernie in just one second first
there are a lot of things in life that
aren't right if you put carpet in your
shower screen doors on submarines
helicopters with ejector seats there are
lots of bad ideas in life well one of
those bad ideas is over paying for
wireless with mint mobile you can cut
your wireless bill down in just 15 bucks
a month
they've reimagined Wireless making it
easy and online-only which means they
can pass significant savings directly to
you
you can save like a thousand bucks a
year
in mobile without sacrificing quality
service mint mobile makes it easy to cut
your wireless bill down in just fifteen
bucks a month use your own phone with
any mint mobile plan you can keep your
old number along with all your existing
contacts with mint mobile choose between
plans with 3 8 or 12 gigabytes of 4G LTE
data stop paying for unlimited data that
you'll never use every plan comes with
unlimited nationwide talk and text if
you're not a hundred percent satisfied
MIT Mobile has you covered with their
seven day money-back guarantee did your
old wireless bill start saving right now
with mint mobile to get your new
wireless plan for just 15 bucks a month
and get the clan shipped to your door
for free go to mint mobile comm slash
Ben that's em int mobile comm slash man
cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks a
month get free shipping on your mint
mobile plan at mint mobile comm slash
Ben that is mint mobile.com slash Ben go
check them out right now ok so as I say
Bernie Sanders leading the way and
Bernie Sanders sort of trying to run
away from the fact that he's a communist
at least he was in his past and sort of
not so for example he was asked about
his democratic socialism last night he
says not my democratic socialism is
buttoned like washing communism No very
very different my father's family left
Soviet Russia in 1979 fleeing from some
of the very same socialist policies that
you seemed eager to implement in this
country so my question is how do you
rectify your notion of democratic
socialism with the failures of socialism
in nearly every country that has tried
it is it your assumption that I
supported or believed in authoritarian
communism that existed in the Soviet
Union I don't I never have and I opposed
it what democratic socialism means to me
is we expand Medicare we provide
educational opportunity to all Americans
we rebuild our crumbling infrastructure
in other words government serves the
needs of all people rather than just
wealthy campaign contributors so this is
his story now is that he likes Norway
and Denmark that wasn't his story back
in the 1970s in the 1980s when he was
mayor of Burlington Vermont
then he full-out endorsed communism he
endorsed breadlines
endorse nationalization of major
industries he honeymooned in the Soviet
Union so yeah you did used to believe
that and as you'll see it gets very
awkward for Bernie when he's calling on
this I remember
for some reason of being very excited
when when Fidel Castro
the revolution in Cuba I was a kid and I
remember reading that and it was just
seemed right and appropriate that poor
people were rising up against rather
ugly rich people you know as a socialist
the word socialism does not frighten me
and I think it's probably fair to say
that the Nicaraguan government is
primarily a socialist government you may
recall way back in most of 1961 they
invaded Cuba and everybody was totally
convinced that Castro was the worst guy
in the world all the Cuban people were
going to rise up in rebellion against
Fidel Castro dead forgot that he
educated the kids gave them the health
care totally transformed a society but
just because Ronald Reagan dislikes
these people does not mean to say that
the people in their own nations feel the
same way okay that's amazing that's
amazing so there he is endorsing
outright communist revolutions across
South America again he there's video of
him shirtless singing in the Soviet
Union he talked about how bread lines
are good because at the end of the lines
you get bread so he was asked about that
last night by Chris Cuomo who asks him
okay so you say that you're just for
democratic socialism but in the past he
talked about large-scale nationalization
of industry and listen as Bernie refuses
to answer the question you used to argue
that you should have government control
the means of capitalism of our energy
companies founded I think in the 70s
okay I said what I said and that is I
want to live in a nation in which all
people in the wealthiest nation in the
history of the world can have a decent
standard of living we can do what other
nations in the world are already doing I
mean the ideas that I'm advocating for
you tonight you know they're not so
radical I believe in a nation in which
we guarantee fundamental economic rights
basic necessities of life to all of our
people oh okay so he's just gonna avoid
that question so no he said what he said
a nice little grin was what I said what
I'm not going to say that out loud
I'm going to pretend I didn't say it but
I did say it and I still think it kind
of well turned Bernie Sanders now as
you'll see a normal Democratic Party to
go
that dude crazy and they would run the
other way but that is not this
Democratic Party no indeed so the next
candidate up is of course Kamala Harris
OH Kamala Harris is seen by many people
as sort of the the silent frontrunner
that she really is the front-runner but
she isn't
emerged from the pack as of yet the
reason that she is of course the
front-runner is because she is a black
woman she has no other qualifications
she's a senator just like Kirsten
Gillibrand or Amy Klobuchar no one's
talking about them they're only talking
about Kamala Harris because she is a
minority woman as opposed to just a
white woman and that means that she must
be special so let's play some Kamala
Harris music right here Pamela Harris as
we all know is a little unpopular with
her own base because she was Attorney
General of the state of California and
even though she was very soft on crime
if you're even a little hard on crime in
the Democratic Party this makes her life
not all that wonderful so Harris is
trying to run away from her own record
there and she was following Bernie
Sanders directly off that cliff so if
you think back about ten minutes about
ten minutes ago we talked about Bernie
Sanders saying that the Boston Marathon
bomber should be able to vote Kamala
Harris has asked the same question
listen to her below this one the right
to vote is inherent to our democracy yes
even for terrible people do you agree
with that senator I agree that the right
to vote is one of the very important
components of citizenship and it is
something that people should should not
be stripped of needlessly which is why I
have been long an advocate of making
sure that the formerly incarcerated are
not denied a right to vote people who
are in convicted in prison like the
Boston Marathon bomber they should be
able to vote I think we should have that
conversation I think we should have that
conversation
she's such a terrible candidate leave
Bernie Sanders just says yes so I think
we should I think we should study it I
think we should have a conversation I
think we should have a conversation
means no but I'm too cowardly to say so
it means I'm a coward so I'm not
actually going to say yes I'm scared of
my own base so I won't just give them a
straight answer which is amazing how are
Democrats so afraid that their own bases
in favor of the marathon but the Boston
Marathon bomber voting they think that
there is a hue and cry among Democratic
voters in Ohio and Pennsylvania and
Michigan and Wisconsin we must let the
Boston Marathon bomber vote and what in
the actual hell do they think there are
millions and millions of Democrats are
like yeah we need to let murderers vote
it's a high priority guys gotta let
murderers vote the fact that come
Harris thinks that Bernie Sanders that
his heart is where the Democratic
Party's heart is demonstrates what you
need to know about the modern Democratic
Party Harris by the way is not averse to
top-down control either what she had to
say about guns last night is maybe the
scariest thing any of the candidates had
to say including Bernie Sanders
suggesting that terrorists should vote
Kamala Harris suggested that she is
simply going if you're elected president
she is simply going to ban guns from the
from the Oval Office
she just gonna run roughshod over the
Constitution this supposedly is a lawyer
upon being elected I will give the
United States Congress 100 days to get
their act together and have the courage
to pass reasonable gun safety laws and
if they fail to do it then I will take
executive action and specifically what I
will do is put in place a requirement
that for anyone who sells more than five
guns a year they are required to do
background checks when they sell those
guns okay so she is first of all
falsifying a lot of law here but also
what gives her the authority to do this
the Constitution does not work like this
now to be fair to Harris this has now
happened with two straight presidents
Barack Obama said I can't get my
immigration deal
therefore I'm just gonna do what I want
therefore I'm just going to declare that
all dreamers are here legally and I'm
gonna move forward as though everyone
was fine with that because what the hell
I'm gonna do what I want to do and then
Donald Trump did the same exact thing
with regard to appropriating money for
his wall he argued with Congress there
was a government shutdown over it he did
not get his money and now he says he's
going to declare a national emergency
and shift the money from one area to
another area well he could have done
that right away supposedly according to
trump if you had the inherent authority
to do so he didn't really think he had
the inherent authority to do so he
expanded executive authority to do that
and as we said if you are Kamala Harris
or any other Democrat you feel there are
no limits to executive power the
legislature has done it has done a
terrible terrible job of maintaining its
own control of the purse strings of the
power in American government the way
government is supposed to work is if
Congress says no no is the answer
government does not work like my
five-year-old with me and my wife where
you go to one and you ask the question
and if they say no you go to the other
and ask the question and see if they
also say no that's not the way this
works legislation originates in Congress
it originated
the legislature that is their job is to
legislated is filled with legislatures
but according to Kamala Harris when
she's president she's gonna give
Congress a hundred days to act and then
she's just gonna declare herself
dictator and start declaring policy
that's pretty scary stuff the American
people don't favor this either now the
biggest problem for Kamala Harris is
that she is trying to out radical Bernie
Sanders just like as we'll see Elizabeth
Warren is trying to out radical Bernie
Sanders everybody trying to out radical
Bernie Sanders so now she's declaring
that we should let people vote at age 16
so just to be fair about this these
Democrats are now declaring that we
should pay for everybody's college
everybody's health care you should live
in your parents basement until you're 35
you should never get married you should
be a ward of the state basically until
you're ready to leave like twenty nine
thirty years old but at age sixteen you
should be able to vote so prisoners
should vote terrorists should vote
sixteen year olds should vote solid
platform you got going here Democratic
Party do you believe that Americans
should have to fight to vote at age
sixteen I think that there is no
question that if we are looking at what
is going on in our country we are
putting more responsibilities on people
at a younger age and the larger number
of people that we can involve in the
electoral process I think the more
robust it would be you can look at what
we are not doing for our students for
our teenagers and even younger and I
believe that if they had greater
political power maybe we would get our
act together a little bit better than
we've been doing and maybe that's one of
the steps toward it oh wow okay so one
of the steps is to let 16 year-olds vote
yes 16 year-olds who are not in any way
fully brain developed they can there's a
good question as to whether 16 year old
should be allowed to drive but no they
should definitely vote they can't buy
alcohol they can't smoke they can't do
most things without parental permission
but they should be able to vote and have
abortions that's that's the thing that
the Democrats want to make sure of now
here's the thing about Kamala Harris the
real problem Kamala Harris has here is
not even her policy with her own base
her biggest problem is that she's super
awkward so for example she awkwardly
laughs her own jokes she has it she has
the Hillary Clinton problem of when she
is in an awkward position she randomly
starts laughing hysterically and
everybody looks at her like why are you
why are you laughing this is weird
that happened last night
on CNN children seniors we all need to
drink clean air and drink clean water
and breathe clean air and you know don't
don't drink when you at that moment when
you awkwardly laugh at your own joke and
everyone in the audience looks at you
like you're crazy yeah Carmel Harris I'm
not sure that candidacy is going
anywhere fast which again is why Bernie
Sanders is doing well now in a second
we're gonna get to mayor Pete Buda judge
who is of course an enormous credibility
in media circles since he mirrors all of
their best friends he went to good
schools he is white and he says all of
these nice liberal things that they like
to hear so he'll get into all of that in
just one second first losing your hair
sucks 2 out of 3 dudes will experience
hair loss by the time they're 35
introducing keeps the easiest and most
affordable way to keep the hair that you
have these fda-approved products used to
cost so much but now thanks to keeps
they're finally inexpensive and easy to
get for 5 minutes now and starting at
just 10 bucks per month you'll never
have to worry about hair loss again
getting started with keeps is really
easy
sign up takes less than five minutes
just answer a few questions snap some
photos of your hair a licensed physician
will review your information online
recommend the right treatment for you
and then it is shipped directly to your
door every three months keeps offers
generic versions of the only two
fda-approved hair loss products out
there some of you've probably tried them
before you've probably never gotten them
for this price keeps is only 10 bucks to
35 bucks a month plus right now you can
get your first month for free that's a
hell of a deal forgetting to keep your
hair to receive your first month of
treatment for free go to keeps calm
slash pen that's ke EPS calm slash pen
that is a free month of treatment at
keeps calm slash ban keeps hair today
hair tomorrow go check them out right
now no reason to lose your hair if you
can prevent it and you need to act right
now so that you don't because once the
hair is gone almost impossible for it to
come back so go check them out right now
keeps calm /ban ke EPS calm slash pen
alrighty so next up on the Democratic
roster of wonderful candidates is of
course mayor Pete Buda judge now mayor
people to judge has been running into a
few problems of late his image is
wholesome clean-cut down with the people
you know he's just that he's a
small-town mayor from Indiana that's
right he's Ron Howard from The Music Man
he can't wait for the Wells Fargo wagon
to come coming down the street oh please
let it be for him
right that is that as mayor Pete's image
he comes off as though he is from a
Norman Rockwell cover that's the the big
blue eyes and and the tie but no jacket
and the whole deal right that's that's
his image well right now his actual kind
of attitude is starting to come out and
that is that Peabody judge seems to be
an elitist he seems to be a guy who is
most comfortable in the halls of elite
folks which makes sense he is a member
of the elite this is a guy who went to
Harvard undergrad and then he was a
Rhodes Scholar over at Oxford this is a
person who speaks many languages in Fay
he's the kind of person that the media
love he he's sort of like John Kerry in
this way the media love John Kerry
because John Kerry could speak French
it's the same thing with Buddha judge
Wow he can speak French that's amazing
you know who else can speak French
everyone in France but mayor Pete Buddha
judge is an amazing guy because he's
smart listen I'm very much in favor of
smart I like smart smart is a quality it
is not a moral quality however but if I
have an option between talking with
someone smart and someone not smart I
will pick the smart human that's good
I'm glad mayor Pete is smart but
sometimes his scorn for folks comes out
and he's been trying to hide it and now
starting come out so we've already seen
him direct his scorn at people like Mike
Pence the vice presidents of the United
States and religious Christians who are
not left-leaning an orientation he's now
claims to be speaking on behalf of God
without apparently having read the Bible
any of the difficult bits in any case
mayor Pete got himself in trouble not
really about that over the last week or
so he got in trouble because he took a
shot at Bernie Sanders his supporters
here is what mayor Pete had to say I
think the sense of anger and
disinfection that comes from seeing that
the numbers are fine like unemployment
slow like all that like you said GDP is
growing and yet a lot of neighborhoods
and families are living like like this
recovery never even happened
their stock it just kind of turns you
against the system in general and then
you're more likely to want to vote to
blow up the system which could lead to
somebody like Bernie and it could lead
you to something like Tom that's how we
got where we are okay so he compares
Trump's and Trump supporters to Bernie
supporters and he suggests that they
want to blow up the system this sounds
exactly like Barack Obama suggesting
that people who didn't vote for him
we're a bunch of bitter cleaners
clinging to God and religion and
xenophobia it sounds a lot like Hillary
Clinton when she said that
people who opposed her or moral
deplorable and now he I mean that's a
big boo-boo that's not just him ripping
on Trump supporters that simmer and make
on Bernie Sanders supporters one of the
crucial things that you're not supposed
to do in politics is rip on supporters
of a particular politician you can rip
on the politician but supporters support
politicians for a wide variety of
reasons those reasons may be bad those
reasons may be good but if you're
running for office the last thing you
want to do is say the supporters of that
candidate those are bad people those
people are somehow morally lacking Mitt
Romney got in trouble for this in 2012
when he suggested that 47% of the
country wasn't gonna vote for him anyway
because they didn't pay income tax now
there was a lot of truth to that but it
seemed as though he was making some sort
of moral judgments about people who did
not pay income tax suggesting that they
were thus dependent on the government
and therefore it didn't have the moral
backbone to vote for him anytime you rip
a giant crowd of people that way while
running for office it's a mistake and
people judge has been trying to atone
for that ever since it is also true that
as buddha' judge rises in the polls up
to about 14 percent in Iowa apparently
which is a massive jump according to the
latest polls only five points back of
both Joe Biden and Bernie Sanders he's
running in a very solid third place
right now out of nowhere he was people
are starting to ask hey why don't you
have like policies like why don't have
any policies on your website so he was
asked about this and his answer was
because policy would make me not look
all that great you've got a website up
but when I go to it I don't see yet kind
of where people judge stands when do you
expect that to be up but weird where
does people to judge Stanley well we've
made it very clear where I stand on the
major issues and we're even putting up a
search tool so people will be able to
search video based on whatever keyword
they care about we're trying to run a
non-traditional campaign so even though
this is going to be a highly substantive
and specific campaign we're not going to
in done date people with the minutiae of
policy before they understand exactly
what the big ideas are the values that
motivate our policies and the impacts
are gonna have on the ground okay so
that is a giant long word salad about
why he doesn't actually have any
policies don't worry as time goes on he
will have policies but he hasn't had any
so far his whole goal in this campaign
is to avoid talking policy because if he
talks policy he's either
have to look moderate or he's gonna have
to look radical and right now you'd
prefer to look neither and just get all
of the rich media attention he has been
receiving he wants to run a beta
O'Rourke 2018 Senate campaign he does
not want to run a Bernie Sanders
campaign also as people who judge rise
in the polls the guns are starting to
turn on him
so last night during his CNN little Town
Hall Pete Buddha judge was asked about
the fact while he's mayor of South Bend
Indiana one of his rather unpopular
policies among minority communities was
bulldozing houses owned by minority
homeowners in order to gentrify and this
of course is not okay with the whoa
crowd in South Bend now the way to
defend this is I was trying to improve
the area these houses were not occupied
if you haven't been paying your bills
the houses get bulldozed if you want to
improve an area and make it not a high
crime area if you want to make sure that
businesses can relocate into low into
low income neighborhoods if you want to
make life better for everybody sometimes
that means that you have to seize houses
that people are living in but not paying
for and bulldoze them but that's not
what people who do judge says instead
he's apologizing for his record as soon
as you start apologizing you're in
serious trouble
this is what Bernie Sanders knows which
is why it's good he has no legislative
record and also will never apologize for
being communist warm here is P Buda
judge though immediately apologizing for
his gentrification plan in South Bend
Indiana which after all is maybe the
only thing he did in sup in Indiana
number one answer I heard city wide but
also an answer I heard in particular
from people living in minority and
low-income neighborhoods was do
something about the vacant boarded up
and collapsing houses around me in
particular what we found is that our
policy tools didn't do a great job at
first of being able to tell the
difference between a sort of big bad
out-of-town landlord who just started
these houses as lines on a spreadsheet
and never even visited South Bend and
somebody who maybe had three or four
properties in town as investments or one
area where we had a lot of issues but
somebody would buy a house believing
they could fix it up and not even know
that it was on the vacant and abandoned
list and that we were coming in to
demolish it okay so you know there is
there is Buddha judge basically
explaining away and also apologizing for
his policy in just a second we'll talk
about what Buddha judges cans it is he
really is about and why he is popular
right now and why I don't think that
last and then we have to get to the
Native American princess Elizabeth
Warren who also joined CNN we have
talked Sri Lanka a lot coming up first
let's talk about saving some money right
may disagree on politics but we can all
agree that we should save some money and
this is why you need to be using honey
honey is a free shopping tool that
automatically saves you money by
searching the internet for the best
promo codes whenever you shop online
that means you get the best deals
without even trying on sites like Amazon
eBay Walmart Macy's Domino's and more
yeah I use Amazon all the time I've
saved money on free weights which we got
for exercising I have saved money on
child products because we get that sort
of stuff for my kids all the time
honey does all of this stuff for you
automatically it always applies the
biggest discount right at checkout honey
has over 10 million members over a
hundred thousand five star reviews honey
members have already saved more than
eight hundred million dollars which is
not bad for something that is completely
free and just takes two clicks to
install never worry if you're overpaying
again with honey you can shop with
confidence knowing you're always getting
the best deal again I my family uses
honey all the time
I installed it it just runs in the
background of my computer I don't even
think about it it's great there's no
reason not to add honey to your browser
today and it's free to use it installs
in just two clicks get honey for free at
join honey calm and slash pen that is
join honey calm slash pen honey is the
easiest way to save money while shopping
online you can shop with confidence
you're always going to be getting the
best deal join honey calm slash men that
is join honey dot-com slash men go check
them out right now okay we have more
coming up on p-bog edge and elizabeth
warren we'll get to all of that in just
a second first you need to go over to
daily wire comm and subscribe for $9.99
a month and get the subscription means
you get all of the glories of the
venture parrots for two additional hours
a day this week I'm not doing the two
additional hours because it's Passover
next week I will be back on doing the
two additional hours and you can check
out two additional hours anyway this
week with Jason rants from Seattle and
Michael moles we have all sorts of great
material coming also when we do the
mailbag you get to be part of the
mailbag and when you get the annual
subscription you get this the very
greatest and beverage vessels view it
cast your eyes upon it
behold the Wonder left his tears hot or
cold tumblr it is magnificent also I
have some other news you need to go PI a
copy of another Kingdom Andrew kleavon's
book based on the popular series is
available on Amazon and Barnes & Noble
it is receiving rave reviews I've read
it it's really great if you haven't done
so order your copy of another Kingdom
right now you are going to enjoy
go check out another Kingdom right now
plus today daily we're producing lots of
content Michael Knowles is speaking over
at Cal State Los Angeles now last time
one of us went to Cal State Los Angeles
there was a riot so we'll see how it
goes with Michael Knowles who last time
he went out on the road was shot with
some sort of mysterious liquid
unfortunately he was not injured but
nonetheless he will be trying it again
today at Cal State Los Angeles so head
on over to Cal State LA at 3 p.m. you
can see Noel's give his latest yeah
campus tour speech young America's
Foundation tor speech on illegal
immigration and building the wall free
event at the University Student Union
Theatre located at 51:54 State
University Drive if you can't make it in
person you can watch it live stream on
The Daily wire Facebook page and the
daily white our YouTube channel so go
check that out right now also check us
out over at YouTube or iTunes leave us a
review we always appreciate we are the
largest fastest-growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
all right so we talking about mayor Pete
on CNN and mayor Pete's real appeal to
we left media is three fold well
educated articulate gay and purportedly
religious when I say purportedly
religious I assume that he believes in
God
I assume that he goes to church but when
I say purportedly I mean he obviously
does not believe in central propositions
of the Bible he's in favor of late term
abortion and same-sex marriage on a
private level obviously so and on a
public level so none of those things
mesh well with biblical text so if
you're a biblical believing Christian it
is difficult to take these positions but
because Budaj proudly speaks as a gay
man and as a Christian somebody who
believes in the divinity of Jesus this
means that according to the media he's a
wringing a rebuke to the supposed
religious intolerance of religious
people who have believed in this funny
thing called the Bible see I'm not a big
believer in biblical and biblical belief
where you take 1/2 of the stuff and then
you just don't believe in the other half
of the stuff that's inconvenient for you
I'm not a huge fan of that sort of
picking and choosing among the things
you choose to believe it seems to me
that if you're a Christian and you
believe in Jesus you should also believe
in the stuff that Jesus said in Romans
and Corinthians for example and if you
are a Jew and you believe that God gave
the God gave the Torah at Sinai you
should believe the things that God gave
at Sinai in the Torah like this seems
fairly holistic to me but for the media
what they would love is all of the
guitar playing and pizza eating at
church and a little bit of God talk that
makes you feel warm and fuzzy inside the
same sort of stuff that you would get on
any self-help tour from anybody just
this self up tour and guide is God and
then also just ignore all of the
injunctions about moral behavior so Pete
Buddha judge that is his candidacy that
is his appeal and he sort of admits this
he said yesterday on CNN that if he
hadn't come out of the closet he would
not be running for president now he
doesn't mean it the way that it comes
out but that is obviously true if you
were a straight white male who is the
mayor of South Bend Indiana no one ever
would have heard of him no one would
care about him he would just be a normal
articulate mayor from South Bend Indiana
a heavily Democratic area that votes
8020 Democrat in every presidential
election that would be it South Bend is
not ranked among the top 150 cities in
population he has not done some
masterfully outstanding job in South
Bend that is worthy of national note he
is prominent because he is smart he's
prominent because he is articulate and
he is prominent because he is gay this
obvious and Burton booty judge sort of
acknowledges this although he says no
it's just his homosexuality which gave
him the impetus to run okay I don't care
what give him the impetus to run the
reason people are paying attention to
him is because he is gay where he not
gay hubie martin O'Malley and he cans it
in 2016 on the Democratic side who never
got more than his immediate family to
support him here is Pete bootie judge
2015 at 33 is when you came out publicly
how do you think your life would be
different if you would come out before
that I started really thinking about how
you only get to live once and and I came
out and I started dating and and I found
Chaston and even though in the past I
was mystified by the idea of how anybody
any of my fellow mayor's or elected
officials ever managed to do that job
and also be be in relationships and be
married I don't know how I do this
without him so I guess another way to
answer your question is I would not be
running for president today if I hadn't
come out okay that is also probably a
lie I mean the fact is that he was
awarded most likely to become president
in his high school yearbook he's been
constructing his resume since he was in
high school and junior high to be
President of the United is fine I don't
have a problem with ambition the
founders thought ambition was good the
point that I'm making is that his appeal
obviously in the intersectional culture
of the Democratic Party lies in the fact
that he is a gay man now what is truly
amazing about bootie judge again he's
smart but there's a strong streak of
hypocrisy that runs through his
candidacy he has now spent weeks
attacking Mike Pence for no reason he
keeps saying that Mike Pence hates him
there's no evidence Mike Pence hates him
he keeps saying he's been victimized by
Mike Pence Mike Pence has never
victimized him when asked about him
coming out of the closet
Mike pet when asked a bootie judge
coming out of the closet Mike Pence said
he's a good man
Mike Pence personally called bootie
judge when he was activated for the
military Mike Pence has never said a bad
word about people who judge people judge
has had many bad words about Mike Pence
including calling Mike Pence an ungodly
person which again anism is a relatively
amazing statement when no one is
suggesting that people to judge them I
don't think people who to judge is
ungodly I think he's a sinner like all
the rest of us and him purporting to
speak in the name of religion while
simultaneously declaring that
fundamental precepts of that religion no
longer apply that seems hypocritical
to me at best but that doesn't mean he's
irreligious I think he believes what he
believes I think we all believe what we
believe but Budi Jenner has been
attacking my pens and then he pretends
though Mike Pence is attacking him he's
at that routine last night Richard
Grinnell who is the ambassador to
Germany nice guy I know rich Rick
Rennell and Rick is over in Germany
right now and he answered for my pens as
a gay man he answered for Mike Pence
said my pence does not hate gay people
and so Buddha judge now suggests that
Grinnell is is hacking him all of this
is really really dishonest kind of a
back and forth public back and forth
between vice-president pence and
yourself over the issue of
discrimination against LGBTQ people and
faiths the current ambassador to Germany
Richard Grinnell is also gay he weighed
in on this saying that you have been
quote pushing this hate hoax along the
lines of Jesse smollett for a very long
time now several weeks how do you
respond to that I'm not a master
fisherman but I know bait when I see it
and I'm not gonna take it oh well you
need nose bait well you were the one
chumming the waters dude you're the one
who started this fight there was no
fight between you and pence you decided
you were gonna say a bunch of stuff
about pens pens responded and I really
oh no I don't I'm not the kind of person
who engages in that sort of fight Buddha
judges most shocking comments I thought
is when he suggested he said God has no
political party which of course was a
suggestion that God is probably if he
had to take an opinion he is apparently
he's got no opinion on late term
abortion apparently here's here's Pete
Buddha judge talking about God and
politics and I get that one of the
things about Scripture his different
people see different things in it but at
the very least we should be able to
establish that God does not have a
political party okay now that is true
and it is not true God it's true God
does not have a political party however
if you are a religious believer
God does have a series of principles and
morals and those principles and morals
are embedded in politics so for example
I can say God is anti-abortion how do I
know that cuz God says so a lot I can
say the God is in favor of traditional
sexual morality how can I say so as a
religious believer okay again I'm
speaking only in the context of
religious belief so if you're an atheist
and you're sitting there shouting it at
your phone or at your radio right now
saying well God doesn't exist that's not
my point you can believe what you want
I'm not talking about public policy
I'm
nobuta judge's statement which is a
religious statement that God has no
political party okay so assuming there
is a God and assuming you are working
with in the judeo-christian framework of
that God God does have principles and
morals embedded in the judeo-christian
system he's not a pantheist presumably
people who to judge he's not somebody
who believes that God is just in the
universe he's not a deist he says he's a
Christian okay so if he's a Christian
you would have to look at you know
scriptural sources and there's very
little in the way of scriptural sources
that suggest that God is in favor of
killing lay killing babies late term
which Buddha judge has supported that
God is in favor of same-sex marriage God
is pretty clear not that God is in favor
of abolishing the set about the notion
of biological sex as the transgender
rights movement seems to want to do in
law that God would be against all of
those things so I don't know which party
God would vote for cuz God doesn't vote
he doesn't have to he's God but I can
say there are a bunch of values that
people judge stands for and has openly
articulated that judeo-christian values
do not mesh with now again if you're not
a judeo-christian value person that's
fine if you don't believe in the Bible
that's your thing fine I'm not making
the case you cannot vote for people who
to judge I'm making the case the peabody
judges case that god is not political in
any way is just a lie it's just not true
there's an inherent politics to religion
as everyone acknowledges which is
specifically why the media are so
enamored of this routine that Budi judge
is doing it specifically why they are so
enthralled with him because he seems to
be speaking from a religious perspective
while trying to knock the legs out from
under scriptural sources on very very
basic issues including abortion
including traditional sexual morality
including the the nature of biological
science right all of these things are
embedded in judeo-christian values
Buddha judge is standing there and
saying as a Christian I reject all of
this okay well he's free to do so but
that is not a good read of the Bible it
just isn't and if you ask anybody who is
more religiously Christian than I they
will tell you the same okay now Buddha
judge is is making gains the person who
is floundering of course is Elizabeth
Warren so final candidate was on CNN
last night was Elizabeth Warren she
stopped by to discuss all things
campaign related
she's been
struggling to gain footing if she'd run
in 2016 I think that she there's a
serious shot rue de nom won the
nomination but time passed her by like
the river of time
you never know she didn't know what was
around the Riverbend as it turns out I
was around the Riverbend was apparently
anonymity so our Native American
princess Elizabeth Warren senator from
Massachusetts she went on CNN and then
she proceeded to dodge a bunch of
questions so she was asked about Social
Security and solvency not a single
Democrat has a serious answer on Social
Security and solvency and Elizabeth
Warren is no exception here she is not
being honest about it
do you have a plan to reform our present
Social Security system to increase its
longevity
so I'm really glad you asked about
Social Security because this is one that
reminds you how things have broken apart
because Washington keeps working for
those at the top it's not working for
people who are relying on Social
Security so your question was is this
something the plan is not hard it's
political will to make it happen I'm
willing to take on that fight it's an
important fight so thank you okay well
that is not answered it's a real problem
and I'm willing to take it on okay lady
thank you
no the great answer so the I mean can
you imagine think of a politician like a
doctor can you imagine you go into the
doctor and like doctor my arm hurts what
can you do about it say you know what
that's a problem I'm willing to take on
and cry put my arm hurts well what
should I do about it
should I have like an x-ray or should we
like get it bandaged and you're like
well you know what that's a problem I'm
willing to handle Thanks Thanks super
helpful Elizabeth Warren other super
super helpful things she said she said
we can't wait any longer on the green
New Deal and then refused to suggest
what exactly are the policies she would
support under the green new deal does
that include Medicare for all does that
include a Federal jobs guarantee aoc
wants or does it just mean that we build
nuclear power plants like what exactly
is she talking about nobody knows it's a
buzz word and she's for it we're running
out of time to make change we must make
change and we must make it now so here's
how I see this I am a strong supporter
of the green New Deal
yeah okay yeah I stopped her stop her
this is nonsense okay god I love the the
the hysterics and the crowd clapping
like seals out there in the audience oh
she said she's for the green new deal
that means she's awesome
okay she didn't say anything guys she
said it's a problem we have to handle
it's a problem we have to hit Luke
Warren 2020 it's a problem we have to
handle thank you Elizabeth Warren my
favorite part of the Elizabeth Warren
quiz section here is when she was asked
about the fact that she wants to break
up the big tech companies and she said
well yeah sure I mean I like order
things from Amazon and everything okay
well if you think the big ten companies
are so bad why are you ordering from
Amazon at least the people who hate
chick-fil-a chick-fil-a enough not to
shop there and she says that Amazon
should be broken up but sure I get cheap
products from Amazon it's pretty great
for the consumer and all so that's the
reason I want to see the two of them
broken apart do you order stuff from
Amazon sure you do what was the last
thing you ordered you do a mailbox okay
and everybody's like what why'd you
order a mailbox from Amazon that's a
weird thing to do who orders a mailbox
by the way that's that isn't that is the
mark of a of a non millennial woman
right there ordered a mailbox from
Amazon they're like who even gets mail
anymore pretty pretty amazing stuff so
solid stuff there from from Elizabeth
Warren okay meanwhile I do have to know
that the media contingent not one
mention last night in the entire night
of Sri Lanka not one mentioned the
entire night over Sri Lanka in an
Islamic radical terror attack that has
now claimed alive of 311 people not one
Democrat mentions this not one Isis has
claimed responsibility for Sri Lanka the
Sri Lankans government says it has
informations that the information the
bombers were reacting to last month's
terror attack on mosques in New Zealand
I have my doubts that that is true
specifically considering the complexity
of this terrorist attack eight
simultaneous suicide bombings I don't
think in 34 days you're able to get a
terrorist attack of that magnitude
together simply in response to
Christchurch but was Christchurch a bad
thing of course Christchurch was in
tremendous active evil you know it is
also an act of evil murdering 311 people
at church on Easter Sunday and though
both of those acts of evil deserve to be
condemned with all the enthusiasm
that we can muster I'm only noticing
that level of enthusiasm in condemning
Christchurch from the left media and
that runs in spite of the fact that
Christians are under attack worldwide
and rapidly rising rate according to
Christian Christopher von retrac at the
Washington Times violence against
Christians has been escalating steadily
over the past few years according to
international observers open doors USA a
mission for persecuted Christians
estimated that violent attacks on the
faithful doubled from 2017 to 2018
approximately 11 Christians dying every
day for their faith nearly 50
worshippers were killed on Palm Sunday
2017 by bombers who targeted Coptic
Christians in Cairo are supposed to
ignore that because Christians in the
West
raaah stood out is a good piece on this
today at the New York Times because
Christians in the West are generally
well-off they do real well and because
Christian societies tend to be wealthier
we forget about Christians were not in
Christian societies or victimized on a
regular basis in Pakistan that same year
9 Christians were killed a week before
Christmas by suicide bombers linked to
Isis Sarah Cunningham senior director of
communications for open doors USA said
there's a specific pattern of violence
around Christian holidays such as Easter
and Christmas which obviously is true
but how does the Washington Post respond
to all of this with this article
Christianity under attack Sri Lanka
church bombings took far-right anger in
the West so weird weird
I don't remember after the Christchurch
attacks and the entire media going nuts
and suggesting that this was evidence of
widespread Islamophobia rooted in
traditional conservative thought I don't
remember them saying I remember them
saying Islam under attack
Christchurch attack prompt calls of
Islamophobia from far left I don't
remember that but according to the
Washington Post it's only the far right
that is upset about Sri Lanka there's
this article in the post and they say to
some it was further proof that
Christians in many part of the world are
under attack several churches were
targeted in Sunday's bombing attack when
they say marine lepen and then they cite
Germany's far-right alternative for
Germany framing the bloodshed as an
attack against Christians well so the
hell what I mean like that's that that's
what happened I'm confused are we
supposed to pretend that it wasn't an
attack on Christians the fact that the
Washington Post's first for
spawns - this is how dare we focus on
the victimized Christians obviously
that's just the far-right it shows
everything that is wrong with the media
and a democratic party that have
followed the media because the
Democratic Party and the media basically
merged and are now - the the press are
basically the press wing of the
Democratic Party at this point okay time
for some things that I like and then
some things that I hate so things that I
like today there's a fantastic
philosophy series by a Catholic
philosopher named Frederick opalsen this
is recommended to me I was at Loyola
Marymount University last month I had
actually not seen this which I'm
surprised by because it's pretty famous
there's this this series called the
history of philosophy it's 11 volumes it
goes all the way from Greece and Rome up
through the moderns and it's really
terrific I've been I've been reading it
over the holiday and it's really
enjoyable so if you're looking for a
broader survey a deeper survey of
Western philosophy then my own the right
side of history which continues to be on
the bestseller charts mine is sort of an
introduction to the introduction so if
you want to read my book and then read a
history of philosophy I think they pair
really well together there's a deeper
look it's also as I say 11 volumes that
means that it's probably 4,000 pages or
5,000 pages but it is totally worth
going through I'm enjoying it a lot as I
read it thanks to the professor at
Loyola Marymount who suggested it don't
want to name you for fear of getting in
trouble with your own administration a
history of philosophy by Frederick
coppleson go check that out ok time for
anything that I hate ok so on Friday
the New York Times right before Passover
because this is what they do every
Jewish holiday the New York Times runs
an anti-semitic piece this is their
favorite thing to do I don't know why
they do this but they did it they've
done it I think his last Passover they
did it on Sukkot like every time the
Orthodox Jews take the day off they're
like you know it'd be a great idea
let's smack them Jews so the New York
Times ran a piece on Friday by a writer
who's reported for the New York Times
and edited at the New York Times
magazine he never acknowledged that
Jesus was Jewish said it was unlikely he
was white and said he was likely to have
been a Palestinian this guy's name is
Eric Coppage he said as I grew older I
learned that the fair-skinned blue-eyed
depiction of Jesus has for centuries
adorned stained glass windows and altars
and churches throughout the United
States and Europe but Jesus born
Bethlehem was most likely a Palestinian
man with dark skin um so
it is true that Jesus probably looked
like my father-in-law he's probably a
short Jewish guy of Middle Eastern
descent but he was not Palestinian you
know I know that Jesus was not
Palestinian because the term Palestine
was invented for hundred hundreds of
years after Jesus's death hundreds of
years after Jesus's death the term
Palestine was invented okay so that that
is not that is not accurate
this was called he was a Judean man he
has described in the Gospels as a Judean
man right as a Judean his parents were
Judean and they were Jewish
the term Palestinian originally offered
to referred to Jews the term Palestinian
now refers to Syrian and Jordanian and
Egyptian and Saudi Arabs who are living
in British Mandate Palestine at the time
of the division of that mandate into
Israel and Jordan and Transjordan and
then the Palestinian areas that deal was
rejected of course by the Arab states
themselves but the notion that Jesus was
an Egyptian Arab or that he was a Syrian
Arab Arabs were not even in this part of
the world at that time the Arab the Arab
conquest of the regions didn't happen
until hundreds of years later the term
Palestine was not used until generations
later so he was not a Palestinian man as
just historically inaccurate in the
600-plus words of the peace Jesus is
never acknowledged that Jesus was Jewish
instead the idea is that Jesus was a
Palestinian Arab and thus the Israelis
are just like the Romans today which is
pretty anti-semitic crap Coppage opine
now even though cultures across the
world may at times show Jesus that
reflects their own story a white Jesus
is still embedded in the Christian of
the Western story of Christianity and
has often become impossible to separate
Jesus and white from the American psyche
I am interested in how white Christians
feel about images of Christ how do you
feel about the possibility that Christ
may not have looked the way he's been
portrayed for centuries in the United
States and Europe if you've seen Christ
depicted as a man of color what was your
reaction well I don't know I mean every
question I've ever talked to
nods when I say Jesus probably didn't
look like an Aryan and I've never met a
Christian who's like how dare you sir
Jesus looked exactly like a Nordic guy
he looks exactly like a Dane Jesus I
mean
I've never met that person Arabs didn't
conquer the area until 700 years after
Jesus was crucified Jesus was not an
area wasn't was not an Arab and also the
name Palestine only came into existence
after Romans exiled the bulk of the
Jewish people from Judea in the second
century AD notice the term ad that be
after Jesus right second century long
after Jesus lived and that's when the
Roman Emperor Hadrian exiled the Jews
and then he decided to call it Palestine
specifically in order to mock the Jews
by naming it after their historic
enemies the Philistines so well done New
York Times always always covering the
news in the worst possible way pretty
impressive stuff okay
we will be back here tomorrow and I will
see you then I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
this is the Ben Shapiro show executive
producer Jeremy boring senior producer
Jonathan hey our supervising producer is
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stephens edited by Adam sy
events audio is mixed by Mike Carmina
hair and makeup is by Joshua alvera
production assistant Nick Sheehan the
Ben Shapiro show is a daily wired
production copyright daily wire 20 19
I'm Michael Knowles host of the Michael
Noel's show Democrats kick off a major
2020 townhall by endorsing voting rights
for terrorists and rapists we examine
the novel electoral strategy check it
out at daily wire.com